你条件比我好呀，你比我有能力啊，我接纳我是抱大腿的，我接纳我就是看中能力比我强，我也接纳我爱你更多。我就是来抱大腿的那我有这个能力抱上这个大腿也是我的本事。你要说思想转变成这样的话，这日子反而好过。很高兴能跟你连麦，就是我想咨询一下我的感情问题还有工作问题，我先介绍一下我的基种情况啊，我今年26岁，在国企工作，年收入的话大概8~9万。然后整体身高呀，性格还可以。现在的男朋友比我大8岁，他自己开公司，年收入好的话，大概能在200个W，差一点的话是100个W。存款的话，有1000个W。其他的配置的话，就一般。然后他的性格挺好的，然后情绪也比较稳定，我觉得他有解决问题的能力，人品也很好，他很孝顺，然后也很喜欢孩子，因为我自己也很喜欢孩子，我自己是想生两个孩子的。我父母的情况就是，父母之前是在做生意，然后有两层商铺起来收租，但目前没有做生意了，就是在照顾我哥哥的孩子。就我哥哥的婚姻现在就是一塌糊涂，所以，就他们俩没有收入，就只靠租金。男方父母都是退休人员，然后大概。
退休工资在一个W，就是我的问题点是，首先这个男生他比我大8岁，然后我挺喜欢他的。我自认为不是个恋爱脑，但是不知道为什么，就是跟他谈了恋爱之后，我觉得我好像是个恋爱脑了。但是他因为年龄摆在这，所以他比较成熟，他对我可能没有像我对他那么喜欢，我觉得他没有那么愿意给我花钱，就是如果继续下去的话，今年肯定是要结婚了。我不知道我对这个人的选择对不对，他之前有结过婚没有，就这些，我全部都确定过了。因为我们家是在一个地方的，然后我爸爸也全部都去打听过。那你们有可以的地方，有的正常的是不是？嗯，对，其实你本身啊，你条件也挺好的，你又年轻26岁，然后又是国企啊，相对比较稳定，身高啊，性格啊，各方面条件都很好。他那头因为他经济条件好一点嘛，他身上有什么其他的比你弱一点的地方吗？比如说长相身高有什么比你弱一点的地方吗？长相和身高的话，其实跟我是没有那么匹配的。他然后开了就是相对于我的身高的话，他是有点矮，但是在一米七五整体还好，然后他做的那个事业，他是老板嘛，对他自己开公司。
做的事业是哪方面的呢？半导体行业，他跟你相处到现在总共多长时间了呢？有一年了，那他对你的这个好，或者对你的这个青睐，他表现在哪些方面呢？老是他主动来找你，还是老师你主动找他呢？我感觉是相互的，就是我有找他，他也有找我。那结婚就是事，主要是你在推动，还是他在推动呢？他在推动，毕竟比他年龄小好几岁，所以我就感觉我自己没有那么着急相处的这一年当中的话，他对你有什么表示呢？在物质上，可是我觉得他没有那么愿意给我花钱，因为他这个人整体比较抠门，但他也没有说不给我花钱，就大概每个月的话都会给我三四千块钱。但是是我问他要，然后他才会给我。然后，我们俩平常出门的话，就是所有的费用基本上都是他来。但是，我觉得他没有很主动过生日呀，什么的他也会送我礼物，大概也是在三四千这样恋爱这个阶段，你为什么要问他要钱呢？就我有一次要交保险，然后费用不够了，然后我就说我没有钱了，他就说我给你，我说那你给我吧，那是他每个月都会给你三四千块钱嘛，后来也不是就是得问问他要，就是我如果有钱的话，我也不会经常问他要钱。我觉得也有点尴尬，我跟你。
跟你讲啊，姐妹啊，跟这种收入比你高很多的男人相处的话，其实挺忌讳在没有结婚的时候，没有确定关系的时候就问他要钱的，因为他会很排斥这个东西，知道这是一种忌讳。你要说大家都结了婚了，成夫妻了，或者共同养孩子了啊，问他要钱，这顺理成章。但是在搞对象的时候，以后如果你们遇到经济条件非常好的男生的话，很忌讳这个东西，不要在谈恋爱的时候就伸手问他要钱。从你现在的描述来看，如果这个男生第一，他爸妈确实是退休的，第二，你们是在一个地方的，知根知底的，第三，人家确实有这个收入，有这个经济能力，第四，他也是性格很好，情绪很稳定，人品也很好。他只是有点抠门的话，我感觉这个综合条件来说的话，也还是一个很好的一个选项吧。但是，你的心理预期就要调整了。既然你知道他抠门，既然你知道他虽然挣钱多，但他不舍得花钱的话，以后成了家就不要因为这个事情就心里不平衡了，又觉得怎么怎么地了。就这意思。好的，他的年龄摆在这儿，所以我觉得他比较成熟，但是相对于他的年龄，我没有那么成熟。我觉得我的核心一直都没有他稳定，然后我就很容易在我们俩的感情内耗。就我总是想着要跟他分手，但是睡一觉起来就觉得他整体。
条件还可以，是一个适合结婚的人。你不是想着要跟他分手，你只是觉得他没有那么爱你。你想用各种方法来衡量一下，你在他心目中到底占多大的分量。这个事儿呢，千万别这么干。就以后啊，假设结了婚了，千万别因为一点小事儿就闹离婚啊什么的。因为有的时候，如果我们作为经济的弱势一方，又是情感的弱势一方的话，你只有接纳自己处于弱势这一方，这日子才能过好。别经济上处于弱势一方，感情上处于弱势一方，又非得在他面前去求一个证明，证明他在乎我那日子。我跟你说，3年就过崩了，就是在心里，我接纳你条件比我好呀，你比我有能力啊，我接纳我是抱大腿的，我接纳，我就是看中你能力比我强，我也接纳我爱你更多。我就是来抱大腿的那我有这个能力抱上这个大腿也是我的本事。你要是说思想转变成这样的话，这日子反而好过。嗯，你知道吗？好的，我知道了。嗯，还有一个工作问题，就是我在国企工作嘛，我们现在的公司就是一直在走下坡路，就是很大幅度的能看出来在走下坡路，然后一直在扣钱，然后扣绩效。然后我在这里工作的也特别的不快乐，就是我这个男朋友他就给我介绍了另外一份工作，大概工资的话能比。
这里将近多1.5倍，我就在想我要不要跳过去，因为我一直在纠结要不要跟他分手。我觉得如果我因为他的关系，我跳到这个公司了，首先我放弃了国企，就虽然他在走下坡路，但是他很稳定。然后其次就是我是通过他的关系建立了公司了，那我以后肯定就算我真的有一天因为一些事情我想跟他分手了，那这个工作就好像不是真正属于我自己了啊。所有东西都要建立在自己的能力，我的能力边界是什么？比如说，我我起这份工作不要了，我不借助他的能力的情况下，我是不是随时能找一份相同类似的工作？因为所有的关系都是不稳定的，哪怕结了婚，关系都不稳定，包括你和新的同事、新的老板之间的关系都是不稳定的。这个世界上，唯一稳定的就是我自己，我自己内心存的这些力量，我自己赚钱的本事，我自己存的这些技能，这玩意是稳定的。其他所有关系都不稳定。这事儿，我感觉啊，因为在任何一个社会关系当中的话，都有可能出现你不高兴的人和事儿，你要学会的是对不高兴的人和事儿，我如何能够游刃有余的让他和我的世界共存。因为你换个环境，也照样有不高兴的人和事儿。国企不就是图个稳定吗？他找你可能某种程度上也是因为你这个。
国企的身份相对稳定体面吗？我觉得之前是的，现在就是我这个国企还在裁人，然后工作量现在已经在加倍了。他给我介绍的这个工作可能会更加轻松一点。轻松这两个字就是一个涂着蜂蜜的一坨屎。所有的姐妹们，龙飞姐先把这话跟你们每个人都讲透。二十几岁的时候，轻松这两个字就是涂着一层蜂蜜的一坨屎。你二十几岁的时候，你想要什么？轻松二十几岁的时候，我想要。我怎么能够在这个丛林社会上抓到足够多的设备，抢到足够多的这些能够buff叠满的，这些让我更强大的命更硬的这些设备，这才是正经的。你要是去那个很轻松的地方，然后把你驯化了，把你完全弱化了，到时候人家甩你的时候零成本。你既没有社会资源，又没有争夺这个社会生产力、生产资料的能力，你对他又构不成威胁。他甩你的时候，零成本，因为他是一个当老板的，他分分钟公司就能做成负债，分分钟他卡里的一千万就会变成货款，就打出去了。你知道吗？居安思危，没有人可以让我们依靠一辈子，没有人对我们的承诺真的到最后能够完全去兑现，就是我有在弹幕里面看到有前面说我不知道自己想要什么，其实我觉得也。
是的，就好像我从跟这个人谈了恋爱之后一直在想我到底想要什么。就我一方面我觉得他很适合结婚，但我一方面我会觉得为什么他没有我想象中的那么喜欢我来姐妹。我换个角度啊，如果现在是你一年能挣100万，你有1000万的存款，你有良好的事业发展前途，然后你看到一个20岁的一个小弟弟，他是在国企的，请问你会这么全身心的就说哎呀，一定要跟你结婚，你不跟我结婚的话，我可怎么办呢？对吧，你也不会啊，你也会觉得老娘有的是选项啊。我一年能挣一两百万，我有十几万的存款，我又不丑，我个子又一米七五，这么一想，你就明白他为什么对你没有那么上心了对不对？那你就接纳了他对你没有那么上心，你就换个角度想，诶，我就是那个可以让他心甘情愿走入婚姻的那个人，我也挺牛的呀，是他爱我可能只有60分，但是他爱其他人只有30分，那我这60分是不是也排第一了？就这么小问题，好的，我知道了，谢谢刘菲姐，嗯，拜拜，我跟你说，思路一变，生活啊就豁然开朗，刚才那个姐妹就是接纳，接纳我不是那个100分，我就是个60分。他爱我就只有60分，我爱他可能到80分了，但是他身边周围也没有遇到更合适的了。
他可能遇到的就是个30分的20分的，但那最终不是被我拿下了吗？你要以这种姿态和那个什么进入这段婚姻才行。别老想着他为什么爱我，没有80分呢，60分够用了我，真的希望我直播间的所有的姐妹都能够捕捉龙飞姐身上的这个点，就是不断的给自己鼓励，不断的爱上自己，反反复复爱上自己，我怎么这么牛？
当你真的反反复复爱上你自己的时候，你会发现你压根儿不缺人爱。张三李四王五，排个队的爱，你都去给我点关注。